good health now sponsored by partners in
primary care
a new primary care practice has come to
our community's rescue and they're all
about
senior focused care rocky spoke with one
of their doctors to find out more
good to see you again we're telling our
viewers about partners in primary care
introduce them
well parkinson primary care is a senior
focused
primary care practice that just came
into las vegas
and we've opened up clinics here six new
clinics so far
what is senior focused care exactly
people over 65
are in a different phase of their lives
and they have different needs
and we have a model that's been designed
to help
patients from a behavioral
point of view physically socially
emotionally
and what we've done with that it's about
giving you more time and really truly
being your partner
in primary care so it's more time more
space
more respect that you deserve so the
whole team can address
the patient's concerns it starts with an
entire care team actually
we have doctors nurses behavioral health
specialists and a clinical pharmacist
all here that are specially trained in
the needs of seniors
and in that we can provide every single
little need that they have and address
future concerns
and we also have offices that are
dedicated to seniors
we have convenient parking you can park
right up in front
we have spaces that and rooms that
accommodate wheelchairs
walkers and we also have an activity
center with live activities virtual
programming
so there's really a lot going on here we
want to keep seniors moving
engaged physically and mentally happy
and healthy
are you guys actually taking new
patients oh yes we are
um even during this difficult covered
time we are taking measures to make sure
we keep our patients safe
and we also are giving patients the
option to do telemedicine visits
so if we telehealth we can meet a
virtually on computer
on the phone or various ways perfect and
of course
it's time for flu shots do you guys
recommend people come in and do that
with you guys
oh absolutely you know these days now
flu shot
isn't just prevention for you getting
the flu it's very important to protect
your family
and everybody else around you it's
actually an act of love
when you're taking care of yourself by
doing yourself a flu shot
you're helping everybody else in the
community at large
and also at this time while it won't
protect you against
covid it will protect you against the
flu
and if you wind up getting the flu you
might have an increased risk
of getting coveted so we are
recommending everybody
please get your flu vaccines now and you
can call today to become a patient here
we can
get your flu vaccine here
for more information call partners in
primary care at 702-623-3774 or visit
their website
at senior seniorfocusedlasvegas.com
las vegas now returns after the break